president Trump posts a social media
summit at the White House today to
combat big tech censorship meanwhile
star democrat alexandria Ocasio cortez
calls nancy pelosi a racist then Iran
tries to seize a British tanker so the
Brits threatened to blow Iran's boats
out of the water
we asked the important question his
politics ever been this fun all that and
more plus the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some people like to pretend that
politics has never been this bad they
say oh no the chaos in the White House
oh no the chaos and the crazy left and
the Democrats we do this because we like
to feign hardship this is something that
people do this is how people bond
sometimes in groups if you're meeting a
new group of people if you're working
together or you're on a project together
you're at a conference or something
you'll notice people like to complain
because they sometimes bond over
imagined or real hardship but I am here
to tell you especially with today's news
cycle politics has never been this fun
and it is nowhere clearer than in
president Trump's tweet storm about the
social media summit talked about taking
a frustrating news item and turning it
to just pure joy we'll get to that in a
second but first I need to proselytize
to you about my favorite way to sleep
which is purple mattress come into my
boudoir please sleep as though you are
sleeping in my bed am i meeting you
right now I might be I don't know purple
mattress is the greatest mattress ever
invented period I love it I've had the
privilege you know I travel all around
the country to college campuses I had
the privilege on one occasion to stay at
the Ritz Carlton may be the nicest hotel
in the country and every morning I woke
up and I thought ah that just doesn't
feel as good as my purple mattress
purple mattress is the greatest luxury
I've ever slept in it is firm and soft
at the same time how is that possible
it's not an innerspring it's not a
memory foam it's this new material it
was developed by rocket scientists I
couldn't possibly explain it but it's
just amazing it sleeps cool which is
really important in the summer so you're
not gonna just wake up in a puddle of
sweat it's it's an unbelievable bed I
recommend it to all of my friends and
even the ritz-carlton feels like I'm
sleeping on a heap of garbage compared
to my purple mattress how about that it
gives you a zero-gravity like feel for
any sleeping position and you get a 100
night risk-free trial if you were not
fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund you're not
going to want to return it it's just
great backed by 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free in-home setup
old mattress removal you're gonna love
purple right now my listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress that is in addition to the
great free gifts they're offering
site-wide how do you get this amazing
deal take out your phone if you're
driving pull over text NOLs KO wles to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
knowles KO wles
to eight four eight eight eight message
and data rates may apply
KO wles to eight four eight eight eight
there's a social media summit going on
at the white house right now why are
they doing this because the social media
big tech companies every single one of
them have shown that they are willing to
censor conservatives and it started out
with the fringy people like alex jones
and then it moved into more mainstream
kind of comedian types like Gavin
McGinnis then they started going after
steven crowder who's about as mainstream
as they get they're going after all of
us they've demonetised a lot of my
videos on youtube they have restricted
or outright censored some of my videos
on YouTube they restricted my Praeger
you video about how important words are
they're going after all of us so
president Trump is gonna hold a White
House summit here is how he announced to
the summit on Twitter quote a big
subject today at the White House social
media summit will be the tremendous
dishonesty bias discrimination and
suppression practiced by certain
companies we will not let them get away
with it much longer the fake news media
will also be there but for a limited
period the fake news is not as important
or as powerful as social media they have
lost tremendous credibility since that
day in November 2016 that I came down
the escalator with the person who is to
become your future first lady when I
ultimately leave office in six years or
maybe 10 or 14 just kidding they will
quickly go out of business for lack of
credibility or approval from the public
that's why they will all be endorsing me
at some point one way or the other could
you imagine having sleepy Joe Biden or
Alfred Newman or a very nervous and
skinny version of Pocahontas 1000 out of
24
he got that fraction wrong as your
president rather than what you have now
so great-looking and smart
a true stable genius sorry to say that
even social media would be driven out of
business along with and finally the fake
news media I'm sorry I thought I could
get through it and I can't I also want
to point out there was some kind of
random capitalizations in here when he
was referring to
Pete Buddha jej who he calls Alfred E
Newman like the Mad Magazine character
he actually tagged an Alfred e Neuman
account don't know who that person is
this was a masterpiece comparative
literature classes poetry classes are
going to be studying this tweet storm in
the future for its rhetorical brilliance
I'm not kidding what more could you want
this is hilarious and it actually
accomplishes something so a lot of
people what they think is that Trump's
tweet storms are just Ritualist they're
crazy they're weird they're they're
whacky it might be weird they might be
whacky
but they're not gratuitous they actually
are accomplishing something they have a
point he's not just writing them cuz
they're funny he's writing them because
they are calling attention to the social
media summit we haven't heard a whole
lot about this social media summit a
couple headlines here and there but the
mainstream media and the big tech
companies have had every interest in
blacking out it hasn't really been
trending on social media mainstream
media haven't been covering why because
conservatives voices and social media
are a huge threat to both of those
institutions so how does Trump call
attention to it is he sends out this
whacky tweet storm that is too much to
ignore so he how does he goes after the
fake news so he hits them really hard
but maybe they could ignore that then he
says we won't let them get away with it
much longer so there's a threat you
think they probably have to cover the
threat then he just starts talking about
how he walked down the escalator with
his wife and that's kind of strange then
he says he might leave office in 10 or
14 years so he might stay beyond his
constitutional term limits he says just
kidding but you just feel if you're in
the media you have
report on that then he makes fun of Joe
Biden then he makes fun of Pete buddy
judge then he makes fun of Matt of
Elizabeth Warren and as he's making fun
of her he gets the fraction wrong she's
won 1024 Native American he says it's
1,000 out of 24 which would make her
incredibly Native American it would make
her many many multiples Native American
it's 1,000 divided by 24 is quite a lot
then he uses this phrase which is the
one that's actually been plucked out so
great looking and smart a true stable
genius the media at this point even if
they could ignore the other stuff they
can't ignore that because it's hilarious
and they will use that to pretend that
Trump is a crazy narcissist he's not
he's just really really good at getting
attention because he's gotten everyone's
attention obviously he's got my
attention I'm reading the whole thing
but everybody has been doing this in the
mainstream media today and now we're
talking about the social media summit so
what is the social media summit Trump
invited his most ardent social media
supporters to the White House to discuss
censorship so CNN now that they have to
report on this CNN has been describing
them as right-wing extremists that's it
the White House is in chaos is the
right-wing extremists dissent so who was
invited the head of the students for
Trump see a right-wing extremist tiny as
they it's the young Trump supporter a
Twitter account named carpe donk 'dom
which describes itself as the eternally
sarcastic Amin Smith specializing in the
creation of memes to support President
Donald J Trump and the talk-show host
Bill Mitchell who is a huge Trump
supporter his twitter banner is just
like a glowing golden picture of Donald
Trump these are not far-right people
he's not inviting white nationalist
neo-nazis all the regular gang that the
mainstream media scare mongers with he
is however inviting eccentric people I
mean one of the guys names is carpe
dunked oh that's pretty eccentric this
sends the right message the message that
this is sending is that the White House
is not going to
back down on this so he's threatening
he's saying there will be consequences
what will the consequences be I don't
know he probably doesn't know but he's
saying there will be he then holds the
summit which in itself shows that
they're taking this seriously and then
crucially he's not just inviting the
buttoned-up people he's not just
inviting the ones who have bowties on
and who are really super serious and
have a lot of law degrees he's inviting
these hardcore pro Trump social media
accounts with names like carpe dogdom
he's saying we're not going to give an
inch we're not going to apologize at all
it sends an important message into 2020
we'll get to that in a second and then
we'll get to this wonderful story about
Nancy Pelosi but first I have to thank
another sponsor and invite you once
again into my boudoir you are so lucky
today I've got to tell you about bold
and branch sheets you know really the
same could be said of Boland branch I
talk about how much I love my mattress
Bolin Branch sheets is another example
of if you ever have the opportunity to
stay at some of these SuperDuper nice
hotels one thing you'll notice is that
the sheets feel completely different
from the sheets you have at home because
the sheets you have at home if you're
anything like me you you would go out
and buy the cheapest things at the store
and maybe they feel like sandpaper or
they feel like really nothing at all
Boland Branch sheets give you that
five-star hotel luxury quality at home
for an incredible deal when I started
registering for my wedding gifts last
year when I was getting married I would
notice that really high quality luxury
sheets could cost a thousand dollars
sometimes they could cost even more than
that Boleyn branch sheets give you
exactly the same quality but they're
only a couple hundred bucks how do they
do that because they cut out the
middleman so they go direct to you they
pass on those savings from bedding to
blankets everything Bowl and branch
makes is made from pure 100% organic
cotton
it means they start out very soft
they're already very soft once you try
them but they get softer over time
somehow the sheets get better the more
you use them shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights there is no risk
and no reason to not to give them a try
you know that I take my sleep very
seriously I need at least 19 20 hours a
night of sleep to maintain this beauty
you know I need to to make sure I get my
beauty rest Boland
and sheets are top of the line to get
you started right now my listeners will
get $50 off your first set of sheets at
Boleyn branch comm promo code Michel mi
CH AE l $50 off your first set of sheets
is a pretty good deal I'm saving you a
lot of money go to Boleyn branch comm
for $50 off your first set of sheets Bo
ll and branch comm promo code Michael
Boleyn branch comm promo code Michael so
what is the message the Trump is sending
here into 2020 the previous GOP strategy
this is like BT we're dividing time
between BT and I don't know 80 the year
of our Trump in BT in before Trump time
the GOP would have experienced all this
censorship would have experienced all
this slander all of these smears and it
would have stayed quiet don't dignify it
with a response don't acknowledge the
eccentric figures in our ranks people
who give themselves names like carpe
diem and who post memes all over Twitter
no no they're not like we we were just
we just wear bowties and we go to really
fancy lunches in Washington that was the
old that you know I I love george w bush
but george w bush did not know how to
handle the media
same thing with Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
had no idea to handle the media still
doesn't Trump doubles down and he
doesn't just double down and say I
defend this person I defend their right
to free speech he doubles down about how
good-looking he is he invites carpe diem
to the White House
this show is boldness it's not just
words it's not just paying lip service
to giving everyone a fair shot he is
actually exhibiting that boldness
himself we talk about this all the time
the best defense is a good offense this
has always been the case so my only
criticism of this event is that I'm not
there but I'll be in DC in a couple
weeks so maybe I'll get to stop by the
cough ethic palace then that is the hope
this is a good news on the GOP front but
there's even more good news which is on
the Democrat front and this is the
chickens coming home to roost this was
only a
matter of time for years now the left
has baselessly smeared conservatives as
bigots we've warned the whole time this
is harmful to the public discourse it's
dangerous in a democratic republic you
shouldn't be able to just smear people
as bigots the Democrats haven't cared
they've egged it on now the chickens are
coming home to roost because the
Democrats are starting to use this same
cynical strategy against the older
Democrats how did all of this start
how did a OC and her compatriots start
accusing Nancy Pelosi of racism this all
started because the most vocal Democrat
showboaters on this border crisis have
refused last week to vote for funding to
help mitigate the crisis that's Ilhan
Omar aoc Rasheeda Talib and Ayanna
Presley these are all the young radicals
who everyday have me wondering if
President Trump should just dissolve the
Congress and named himself King for life
I mean if this is the future of our
country this is the future of Congress
doesn't look very good and so they've
been talking about how important it is
to fund this crisis and get the beds and
get the sheets and help the kids and
then it comes time for a bipartisan
boarder funding bill this had broad
bipartisan agreement and they wouldn't
do it and even mainstream leftists
called them out over this hypocritical
border vote here is Rasheeda Talib on
Martha Raddatz a show on ABC trying to
answer for her hypocritical vote I want
to stop you here for just a second
MacLennan has been sounding the alarm
for months for resources to help the
migrants you voted against the 4.6
billion dollar agency border bill to
deal with the surge of migrants that
included almost three billion dollars to
provide shelter and care for
unaccompanied children acting secretary
McLean and says those funds are critical
to get children out of I'm priority and
transfer even if the bill didn't have
exactly she's proud I'm this some that
she won't even let Martha Raddatz get
the question out because she knows the
question is a total indictment of her so
Nancy Pelosi uses this opportunity to
show look guys
these screeching ignorant young Congress
women don't know anything there they're
not actually the leaders of this party
were the ones getting things done
Pelosi tells the New York Times and
tells Maureen Dowd who's a columnist
they're quote all these people have
their public whatever and their Twitter
world but they didn't have any following
therefore people and that's how many
votes they got pretty harsh criticism
from the Speaker of the House she's
completely right
AOC made it to Congress with 14,000
votes there about a quarter million
registered voters in her district maybe
more than that she got 14,000 votes in
that primary that no one thought was
gonna matter because there was an
entrenched incumbent and Joe it was Joe
Crowley had been there for a long time
and he didn't campaign she went in she
got 14,000 votes she wins the primary
she makes it to Congress so she's got
this huge almost 5 million person
Twitter following no one actually in her
district likes her that much she's
polling very low in her district in fact
part of the reason why a OSI is making
such a spectacle of herself is because
there's a fair chance that she won't get
reelected
there's rumors up in New York that
they're going to redistricting of her
district so she makes this big spectacle
aoc seizes on that
how can a rather Pelosi seizes on that
to thwart AOC now how can a OSI respond
she could respond by showing why Nancy
Pelosi is wrong on the border she could
respond by making a principled argument
about how Congress's complicity in the
border crisis she could respond by
trying to secure the border and
discouraging people from putting
themselves in this position in the first
place by crossing illegally but she and
do any event because she's a hardcore
radical leftist and she doesn't know
anything so instead she called Pelosi
racist and I love it so much oh it's
just the greatest I wish they would do
this all the time she tells The
Washington Post quote the persistent
singling out it got to a point where it
was just outright disrespectful the
explicit singling out of newly elected
women of color take that Nancy Pelosi
wasn't just a
see Ilhan omar jumped on this bandwagon
too she tweeted out quote pathetic oh I
guess she's she must have learned from
bait Oh Aurora canned Corey Booker and
who Leon Castro and Jose Diaz but Lord
that in an America now we speak Spanish
instead of English I don't know I wonder
why they call her an American pathetic
Oh she writes you know they're just
salty about who is wielding the power to
shift public sentiment these days sis
sorry not sorry it's like the worst
combination of millennial thinking and
millennial language the Millennial
thinking is if you disagree with me
you're a bigot everyone who disagrees
with me is Hitler that's that's the
millennial leftist mantra and then
there's all this stupid language you
call each other sis
sister which means you're assuming their
gender and that's horribly offensive as
far as I'm concerned then they'll say
things like sorry not sorry just these
sort of vapid expressions and all the
point the point is just very blunt and
simple it's just coin Nancy Pelosi a
racist what's ironic about this and you
know my feeling is uh Nancy Pelosi there
is no evidence that Nancy Pelosi harbors
some racial bigotry it's like when they
tried to call Biden a racist there's no
evidence of that there is however plenty
of evidence that these young fresh faces
Ilhan Omar Rasheeda Talib those people
that they actually do Harbor racial
bigotry
Ilhan Omar just remind you has claimed
that Israel hypnotized the world and she
is publicly prayed to Allah to awaken
people to the evil of Israel
she has claimed that politicians only
support Israel because the Jews bribed
them and she is also claimed that Jews
aren't loyal to the United States
repeatedly done this
Ilhan Omar Pelosi was the one who had to
say hey lady cool it on the racism Ayane
Presley it was another one of these
fresh faces she tweeted out just
yesterday or two days ago to Kelly and
Conway quote at Kellyanne
oh hi distraction Becky remember that
time your boss tore babies from their
mother's arms and threw them in cages
yeah take a seat and keep my name out of
your lying mouth now for those of
you who aren't familiar with like weird
leftist millennial speak Becky
is a derogatory term for white women so
Becky is considered this generic white
woman named it's kind of kind of like
calling someone a cracker it's saying
you're bland you know to be a white
woman is to be sort of uninteresting and
boring this is the sort of thing that we
would expect from Ayanna Presley to give
you context Ayanna Presley is a graduate
of the same College as Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes and it shows a Presley rather has
never done anything in her professional
life other than work for politicians or
be a politician so she's got a very
narrow and shallow background but just
consider the racism of that statement to
call to criticize Kellyanne Conway on
the basis of her race imagine if a white
congresswoman referred to a black senior
White House adviser by some
stereotypically black name as though
that were a slur she if they said oh hi
distraction Shaniqua oh hi distraction
Chantelle I don't know imagine the
outrage that you would hear from that
actually you don't have to imagine it
because forget a Republican
congresswoman a comedian a generally
left-wing comedian one time made a
racially offensive joke about a black
senior White House aide who was Valerie
Jarrett that was Roseanne Barr who made
that joke
she lost her network TV show within
hours but Ayanna Presley fresh-faced
democratic congresswoman does the exact
same thing to a woman in the exact same
position nothing nada doesn't matter
they don't bring it up this has always
been the double standard and I suspect
it's going to continue to be the double
standard conservatives have always just
dealt with it I mean that it is hard to
fight back against this because we don't
want to get in the muck with them as
much as they do it's just disgusting you
don't want to get into a fight with a
skunk because either way you're not
gonna leave smelling very good but now
finally the Democrats themselves are
experiencing the poisonous fruits of
their decades of a racial divisiveness
this is it I mean Nancy Pelosi in her
whole
crew they stoked this racial resentment
they stoked
all of this racial division and now they
are the victims of it because it never
ends if you have a politics that's just
based on division and entitlement and
resentment and envy that's not going to
end it's not we're not gonna reach a
point where those evil wicked lusts and
passions are satisfied they are ravenous
passions they go on forever and now the
Democrats are eating their own and it's
absolutely fabulous to watch meanwhile
during this entire clown show one story
that has not really gone mentioned is
we've more or less just averted a war
with Iran like yesterday yesterday the
Iranian Islamic Revolutionary Guard
Corps which is the military wing of Iran
attempted to seize a British oil tanker
in the Persian Gulf so Iran for weeks
now has been provoking the west because
they're trying to create a sense of
urgency to save the Iran deal that is
more or less expired and they're trying
to save certain waivers from Europe so
that Europe can continue to cooperate
with Iran and so what did they do they
set a couple oil tankers on fire they
shot down our drone out of the sky
they're trying to provoke us into some
kind of conflict to scare the entire
world about a war in Iran and a war in
the Middle East so that will give in to
them and basically appease Iran because
I guess we've forgotten that appeasement
hasn't worked very well in history so
Iran now the latest thing they've done
because the US and Europe has really
handled these provocations with great
restraint and pretty well so what they
did yesterday is they sent a couple
boats to go seize a British oil tanker
what they didn't expect though is that
the British oil tanker was being
exported by the HMS Montrose which was
much more heavily armed than the British
tanker so you've got this incredibly
provocative maneuver by Iran to
basically force the oil tanker into
Iranian waters so that they can seize it
at that point that's when the Brits
turned their four and a half inch main
gun and their surface ship torpedo
defense on the Iranian boats in addition
to 230 millimeter automatic machine
and AC Kaptur missile system and just
just to kick it all off they deployed
their rocket launching helicopter just
circle the Iranian boats so I it's just
like these little you know irani and
bullies pull up and then you just see
the full weight of the British Empire as
though it were resurrected again in the
Straits of Hormuz and the Iranians back
off of course what are they going to do
they blow them out of the water this was
the this was the the very subdued
response from the British the Royal Navy
HMS Montrose which was also there
pointed its guns at the boats and warned
them over radio at which point they
dispersed classic British understatement
no it's as if to say yes well no no big
deal you know
it's okay we we averted it this was a
major provocation this could have turned
into open fire how was this averted how
was the possibility of war averted it
was because the British were prepared to
go to war I mean this is the premise
that we've been talking about for weeks
the way you get peace is by being
prepared for war you get peace through
strength that's the phrase of Ronald
Reagan it's the phrase of Barry
Goldwater it's the phrase of
conservatives now for 70 years peace
through strength
you'll hear the left try to browbeat
conservatives and say you're war mongers
you're Hawks you're bloodthirsty or
because we want to build up the military
you should point out to them that the
two most peaceful presidents in modern
history are Ronald Reagan and Donald
Trump and those are the two guys who
were called Cowboys those are the two
guys who were called war mongers those
are two guys who have built up the
military dramatically but they've built
up the military because they know by
building it up they're reducing the
likelihood that we're going to actually
have to deploy the military bullies what
when you don't stand up to a bully when
you appease a bully that is an open
invitation for aggression that is an
open invitation for war when you stand
up to them and you launch your your
deploy your rocket launching Helicon
to circle them and you point all your
guns at them and you say we will blow
you out of the water not a shot is fired
that's how you have peace it's a lesson
the left doesn't usually get but we
should send it because the the lessons
of history are clear appeasement doesn't
work and and being prepared for war does
work and moreover imagine if a bullet
had gone off yesterday we would be
talking today about possible war with
Iran and now we don't have to talk about
that now we just get to talk about
Donald Trump calling himself
good-looking and youthful and a very
stable genius and making fun a sleepy
Joe and making fun of Alfred e Neuman
people to judge and watching the
Democratic Party implode on its own
premises because now they're just all
calling each other racists and bigots we
get this wonderful news cycle politics
has never been more fun than it is right
now and the reason it's fun is because
we're extraordinarily prepared we're
showing a tough face two big tech tough
face to censorship tough face to Iran
because we are standing up willing to do
hard things we get to have as much fun
and we get to guzzle as many leftist
tears as we want we've got to get to the
mailbag but first
speaking of leftist ears go over to
Daley wire.com you get me you get the
Andrew flavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the mat well show
you can't ask questions in the mailbag
that's coming up right now you get to
test questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get everything and you get
the leftist here's tumblr never more
important than now and it's only going
to heat up as we approach 2020 go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back with
the mailbag
jumping right in from Brett Michael was
Martin Luther King a socialist yes yes
he was don't take my word for it in a
letter dated July 18 1952 Martin Luther
King wrote quote I imagine you already
know that I am much more socialistic in
my economic theory than capitalistic
that was 1952 one of the lines that
sometimes conservatives will say is that
Martin Luther King for most of his life
was very conservative and he was very
capitalistic and oriented toward free
markets and then only later in his life
in the early 1960s did he become a
little more radical and more socialistic
that isn't true he always had a pretty
socialist economic bent to him both
sides want to claim Martin Luther King
the Conservatives claimed Martin Luther
King because of his most famous speech I
have a dream in which he talks about a
world in which racial division won't
matter and black children will play with
white children and this is a vision the
Conservatives love and the left claims
Martin Luther King because he said
certain things that these days we might
call identitarian he was an advocate for
black people for black rights because he
was economically quite radical he wanted
a jobs program you wanted ant the war on
poverty he wanted more socialist
economics he he at one point talked
about the nationalization of industry as
being a good thing and so he's a complex
figure we we have made him a simple
figure because we claim him as a secular
saint I mean we have a day for him we
celebrate him on the secular liturgical
year we've turned him into a legend that
he really was not you know he had
supreme moral clarity in certain areas
if you watch his speech I've been to the
mountaintop it's one of the most
powerful speeches in American history
and then he was murdered the next day
then you learn that he was one of the
most prolific womanisers in the history
of American politics you realized that
he didn't always practice his moral
vision himself and parts of his moral
vision were wrong like socialism the
worship the veneration of Martin Luther
King veneration is the better word
the veneration of Martin Luther King is
problematic because he's a sort of
problematic figure this is why a lot of
conservatives at the time that the
Martin Luther King Day was created
suggested that if there was going to be
a day for the Advancement of black
people and for the abolition of slavery
and to commemorate the advancement of
civil rights particularly for blacks
that that day should celebrate Frederick
Douglass rather than Martin Luther King
and I I tend to be of that persuasion -
I think Frederick Douglass is one of the
greatest writers in American history
he was profoundly anti-socialist he he
defended the rights of property and this
obviously partakes much more of sort of
our theories of natural law and and the
foundation on which the country was
built so it would be would be nice to
have a Frederick Douglass day would be
nice if he were the one that we were to
look to because unfortunately the left
has a point when they say Martin Luther
King had many leftist dogmas and may
socialist dogmas that's true and it was
true even in the early 1950s from Adam
would you rather meet and have a
conversation with your great-great-great
grandfather or your great-great-great
grandson who would you like to learn
more from the past or the future
certainly my great-great
great-grandfather there's no question
about that I don't care what happens to
my great-great-great-great grandson I
don't care what his world is like it
won't affect me I'll be long dead by the
time he comes around and I won't to meet
my great great great grandson would
compromise my free will because I'd see
how history has unfolded and so I
wouldn't be living it in real time I
would be dooming myself to a sort of
fatalism or a determinism and I don't
want any of that but I am interested in
the future and the way that you learn
about the future is you learn about the
past because we live our lives in
narratives we live our lives and stories
and our understanding of the past
profoundly influences our understanding
of the present which shapes our future
so I would love to meet my great-great
great-grandfather and for a couple
reasons one I think there's a lot that
has been lost over the last hundred or
200 years and so it would be good to see
what's been lost and try to bring it
back on the other hand I think
conservatives in particular are given to
nostalgia which is history after a few
drinks as my priest father brother says
so you you don't want to be
nostalgic either you want to talk to
this guy and he'll tell you yeah things
weren't so great than either yeah we had
the same daily concerns that you guys
have to and this is what happens
generally when you open a history book
when you engage with the reality of
history you realize that the legends
that we tell ourselves aren't quite so
simple and actually what happened is as
a much more complicated and much more
interesting from anonymous dear Michael
king of cofee Fay my girlfriend and I
have had issues lately we've been dating
for four years and recently have
discovered some religious and
philosophical differences in us for
example she's open to the idea of
Christianity but she can't guarantee
conversion she doesn't explicitly
denounce abortion as evil etc what do
you suggest is the best course of action
do I try to convert her to my Christian
morals and beliefs if so how I love her
very much and want to make this work
thanks all the best anonymous I would
not recommend picking a girlfriend or
fiancee or a wife based on some
checklist I would not recommend doing it
based on whether she checks off all the
boxes I think that's so clinical it's
not how love really works and what we're
talking about is a love you're not just
picking someone to serve you you are
falling in love and if you're falling in
love then your love for that person your
desire your will will help to transform
that person you know I've known sweet
little ELISA since we were about 10
years old and we dated in high school we
split for college we got back together
later we've kind of weaved in and out we
were always in each other's lives though
and you learn something which is you
either grow together or you grow apart
and it is almost impossible not to grow
together if you love each other and you
you spend a lot of time together you you
sort of have to I mean it's that's just
how people I mean this happens with your
friends you will be influenced by your
friends you will be known by the friends
you keep and that is all the more true
when you're talking about someone you're
dating or fiancee or wife that's
said doesn't mean you should just lay
off and say oh it doesn't matter at all
if you have religious and philosophical
differences you should talk about it not
in a scolding way not in a debating way
but in a loving way you you think that
you understand the truth and you
obviously then want to convince the
person you love of the truth and I
suspect the same as true of her you know
in that since I've been 10 years old
since I met sweet little ELISA
she and I have held very different views
we've kind of gone in all sorts of
directions and we've grown together now
we agree on
probably most things but it's not always
the case and our views are changing on
things all the time - as new evidence
presents itself and circumstances change
that's the way that I would do it you
know Cole Porter sang let's do it let's
fall in love
he didn't say let's do it let's make
sure that on a checklist we all check
every single box and that you can be a
good spouse for me and fulfill my needs
it's not how it goes you want to make
sure that you don't have fundamental
oppositional ideas of the world I mean
that's gonna be very important when you
raise children but it doesn't sound like
that's quite the issue so I would i
would say go along with it and you know
have a love affair and if it stops
working it's fine break up find somebody
else but if you're just worried about
something thirty years down the road
some problem that you're inventing don't
borrow a problem from the future for
today sufficient to today or the
problems of today from Marc Michael I
think you were off-base when you
criticized Megan Rapinoe for saying I
deserve this when she won the soccer
game I'm not a fan of Megan she and her
team had just won the world woman's Cup
and was basking in that glory that did
look like an alcoholic beverage in her
hand I suspect that her statement was
more from an eagle ego fulfilled than
from leftism she just won big time loved
the commentary
keep up the great work Marc I agree with
you that what she was doing was
fulfilling her own ego I'm just saying
that's wrong and it's it's especially
wrong in sports it's unsportsmanlike
you're not supposed to do that at the
end of the game you're supposed to go
around and say good game to everybody
you're supposed to be humble you're
supposed to obviously take some joy in
your achievement
you're supposed to succeed you're
supposed to win but then you're not
supposed to just talk about how great
you are and say I I deserve this I
deserve this and she wasn't joking when
she said you can sort of joke about I'm
the greatest Muhammad Ali sometimes
would joke about it I'm the greatest in
it but there was a real wit there was a
real cleverness she didn't have wit her
cleverness she said I deserve this she
doesn't deserve this she won a sports
game for a variety of reasons some of
which are her own talent which she
doesn't deserve she was just given her
talent some of which is her skill which
she has worked on and developed over
time some of which are the circumstances
of the people she was playing with and
the people that she was playing against
say thank you said good game to the
other guys say I'm really glad we won
say it's really cool that I get to hold
this trophy saying I'm so grateful to
this country that they would allow me to
represent them to have this great feat
but I deserve this you don't deserve
anything what you're saying is it's not
about leftism it's about ego fulfilled
leftism is ego fulfilled I mean they
actually celebrate pride it's all just
me me me I deserve this I deserve that
that is what it is you're completely
right but that's left is amande that's
no good
from Michael hey Michael it's Michael hi
Michael out of all in the Daily wire
cheers to you for having the best show
that's very kind thank you very much
feel free to gloat well I'm not Megan
Rapinoe so maybe I won't anyways how do
you react when there are things that are
personally challenging for your faith
whether that be history or doctrine good
question history doesn't challenge my
faith one because the history of
Christianity is extraordinarily
misrepresented in the pop culture and as
someone who spent even a few moments
skimming through the history you can
just point out the glaring historical
inaccuracies that that people regularly
point to you know the Crusades is the
worst event in the history of the world
or something like that so the history
wouldn't bother me though even if it
were true because people are fallen and
institutions are imperfect and that's
just that not only is history imperfect
and flawed but so is the present and so
will be the future that doesn't
challenge my faith at all actually my
faith tells us that my faith tells us
the poor will always be with us the the
tells me take up your cross and Barrett
so that's fine the doctrinal aspects are
actually one of the reasons why I'm
Catholic and why I like the Catholic
Church quite a lot is because despite
all of the many many immense problems
over the millennia in the Catholic
Church the weight of their history the
inertia of that institution has I think
protected it from a lot of the doctrinal
craziness that we're now seeing in some
of my other friends churches where
they've got pride flags outside of the
church or they're they're changing
doctrine willy-nilly or they're
radically changing views of the human
person and marriage and abortion and
life and all of these things it's not to
say that there aren't a lot of Catholics
who do want to change those things it's
just that the institution of the church
has prevented them from doing it because
it's so old it is so much history even
the Pope's can't change doctrine the
Pope's are are very fallible when
they're when they're trying to change
doctrine so doesn't present many
challenges I do have a lot of questions
about the faith I mean I don't know I
don't know even one drop in the ocean of
of what the faith is I don't comprehend
even one iota of the faith but to 10,000
problems or 10,000 questions doesn't
make one doubt as I believe John Henry
Newman said from Nick hey Eric's wall
well I'm sorry you had to drop out of
the presidential race me too since
you've acted in plays I'm curious what's
your favorite work of Shakespeare if you
had to pick one personally I don't think
it gets any better than Hamlet but what
is your pick and why you're absolutely
right Nick the answer is Hamlet I think
it's the greatest play ever written and
the reason for that I mean there's a
there's a reason why it is considered
the greatest play ever written why it's
done all the time because it is so
powerfully broadly and profoundly human
and because the play is about a question
that interests me very much which is the
history of Western Christendom
particularly in light of the Protestant
revolution so the play is really all
about the Protestant revolution and the
points that the Protestant
revolutionaries were making
and the problems of the Catholic Church
and the points that the Catholic Church
were making and what it means for Europe
that Christianity had this big split in
Western Europe and the you know even
early on Gertrude the mother of Hamlet
says don't go to Wittenberg don't go to
the center of Protestantism you have
Hamlet debating throughout the whole
play doctrines of the faith from the
very beginning we see the soul of
Hamlet's father is coming out from
purgatory the many Protestants doubt the
existence of purgatory later on Hamlet
doubts the existence of purgatory these
questions are being debated throughout
the whole play and those are the
questions that really are animating our
the modern era from say 1500 to the
present and so we're seeing them work
out there unfortunately the end of
Hamlet is not terribly uplifting that
probably gives you a preview of what
we're in store for
in the modern Western Christendom but
you know it's a it tells the story at
least and that's the purpose of art
alright one last question I'd say one
last question here I'll go down I want
like a good question okay here we go
from Kurt Hey Kofi Thames I enjoy the
show what advice would you give to
applicants who feel they have a
disadvantage in today's world for being
a white male would you suggest they
describe themselves as Native American
following the footsteps of Elizabeth
Warren thanks Matt well you could
honestly say that you could say that you
I'm a Native American Native means born
and from birth and American is American
I'm American from birth I'm a Native
American that's it so I could put that
down in my college essay though I don't
do it it is true that right now there
are laws on the books that discriminate
against white people and Asians for
instance affirmative action in college
admissions there is a sort of sense in
the popular culture that being white is
bad thing you heard Ayanna Presley make
that derogatory comment about white
women before she's a member of Congress
with no pushback whatsoever from the
media beyond race on sex there is a
sense that men are awful they talk about
toxic masculinity women do everything
better than men and men are terrible
knuckle-dragging people who don't
deserve due process or consideration of
their opinions yeah that's all
frustrating and stupid I don't like to
complain about it too much I mean I like
to call attention to it
I'd like to fight it but I don't want to
whine and complain you know everybody's
got a problem and that's ours it's a
line from Tennessee Williams display
Orpheus descending it was a vagabond guy
who he wants to spend the night at a
woman's house and she says no he says I
got nowhere to go and she says well
everybody's got a problem and that's
yours I mean it people have problems
historically in the grand scheme of
things having the Hollywood and the
mainstream media go against you is is
isn't the biggest one also suffering can
be sanctifying so if you do it nobly if
you respond to suffering in a dignified
way that is good for your soul and it's
good for society so that's what I would
do I wouldn't try to cheat it I wouldn't
try to get around it I would just
honestly say I am Who I am I'm not
ashamed of the circumstances of my birth
neither are you I would point out the
contradictions and the double standards
in their racial and sexual arguments and
I would go on with my life and laugh at
all of their craziness because they're
they're the ones who seem to be so upset
and angry and crazed all the time and I
think you and I are having a great time
because politics has never been more fun
all right that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael knurl show
I'll see you next week
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkiss and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy Borah senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 today on the Ben Shapiro show
AOC versus Nancy Pelosi the catfight can
we call it that begins that's today on
the Ben Shapiro show